"It's been a long time"
Hey guys, Pete here. Just a little over eight
years ago the final episode of the eighth season
of Dexter aired as a series finale. Now the
character's been reborn in a limited series
called Dexter: New Blood and this will be
my breakdown of the first episode. It was a
promising reintroduction to the Bay Harbor Butcher
whose circumstances have changed quite a bit in a
decade of hiding. It's been 10 years of abstinence
where he isn't killing anyone not even people who
would be fair game according to the code. Although
we aren't sure how many of those he might have
encountered since he's not actively looking for
them. He may be on the straight and narrow in that
regard but he's still the same character at his
core and as you'd imagine things get complicated.
We'll get into all of that after a quick
spoiler warning. If you haven't watched
episode 1 yet then this video won't be for you.
and with that out of the way let's get into it.
New Blood's first episode is titled "Cold
Snap" and most of the episode is dedicated to
introducing us to the new setting, the new
characters, and setting the table for the
upcoming season. we find Dexter Morgan in December
2021. he's left Miami, he spent at least some time
up there in Oregon where we last saw him at the
end of season 8. he's living in the small town of
Iron Lake, New York and has taken on the fake
name Jim Lindsay, this is a nod to the Dexter
book series author Jeff Lindsay. he seems to have
settled into an unassuming small town existence.
he works at a fish and game store, he's in
what appears to be a healthy relationship with
the chief of police, he's got some land
and some livestock that he looks after,
and he's got a routine that involves stalking
an albino buck in the woods near his cabin.
and he does carry a rifle with him when he does
this but it doesn't seem like he has any intention
of killing the majestic animal. it's like they
have a connection and you can see the symbolism
of its rarity. he lives outside a town alone
but his dead sister Deb has replaced his dead
adoptive father Harry as that voice that he talks
to inside of his head. it's that thing that acts
as his conscience that as viewers we see as
a manifestation. the role she plays for him
doesn't seem to be the same as Harry's who acted
as a guide in relation to the code. Deb seems more
like a partner or support system in this period
of time where he's trying not to kill anyone.
on the way into town we meet his girlfriend
Angela who pulls him over in a role-playing
kind of situation that gets hot until it gets
interrupted. there's a call about runaway sheep
eating a neighbor's winter plantings and there's
no other officers available so they have to take
a rain check. as he walks through town we get
the idea that jim is well known and seems to be
liked by everyone he encounters and we also find
out through Ramon as a helicopter flies overhead
that outsiders come to the town at this time of
year. he's still the donut guy at work or at least
the sweet roll guy and he's still Switzerland
when it comes to weighing in on disputes
and again it seems like he has a good rapport
with his boss. a character named Matt Caldwell
comes into the store to purchase a knife and gun.
he wants something impressive looking that'll out
do what his friend Bill is hunting with and he's
unambiguously unlikable all around. he's loud,
entitled, he claims his dad is someone important
in town, and he's got a high paying job in finance
which all adds up to him carrying himself as if
he owns the place and all of that together seems
to be particularly grating for Dexter as Matt's
trying to convince him to overlook the background
check and just let him have this gun. Dex plays by
the book he doesn't give in and because there's no
secrets in Iron Lake the story of the background
check comes up as soon as he walks into the police
station to see Angela. the woman who was working
dispatch Esther asked him about it and offers up
that she thinks it's probably related to the boat
accident that happened back in Ohio. apparently
five people died and you can see Dexter's radar
going off when he hears this. deputy Logan stands
up for Matt saying that he's a good guy, that
he wasn't even driving, and that he was in the
hospital for weeks. he's sure it was only a really
tragic accident and goes so far as to say that
he bets Matt's record would be spotless until he
looks and sees that okay there are a few spots and
again you can see that Dexter's getting noticeably
uncomfortable and eventually changes the subject.
in her office angela has a board filled with
missing young girls and she just came out of
a meeting where she tells dex that there's
no bodies no pattern and there's no funding
until one of them turns up dead. so it looks like
these girls have been going missing for some time
but there's no evidence that they were killed
or what happened to them. that night Dexter and
Angela go line dancing. it seems like that's what
everyone in town does and we get a little more
acquainted with the people and we get a little bit
more from Matt as he tries to get the rifle again
and he invites Dexter to a party. there's a cut to
a different scene where we see a rig pulling up to
a Caldwell truck stop that's about two miles away
from Iron Lake and we see a mysterious figure get
out. then as Dexter's leaving the tavern we see
that same person watching him and again during
his morning routine the next morning the person's
there makes a noise and scares the deer away. so
he's starting to feel like someone's watching
him and he's right. there's a protest outside
the tavern because the oil billionaire is inside
and using it for his board meeting which is a
problem for dexter who can't enjoy his tuna fish
sandwich for lunch. Angela's daughter is there and
she catches his attention whenever she dumps out
this cup of cocoa that he gave the crowd and it
earns her a stern look from the billionaire. it's
one of those shots where the camera lingers so you
can't miss it. the background check finally goes
through and Fred Jr tells Dexter to deliver the
gun to him. he goes inside there's a party raging
Bill takes him upstairs they find out that Matt's
busy he's having sex with a young woman and
while they're waiting Bill tells him he needs
a straightener and goes in the bathroom to start
snorting lines he brought the girl to the party so
he's distraught and as he's getting high he starts
to open up to Dexter eventually and somewhat out
of the blue he confesses that he covered for Matt
on the boat that matt's father paid him to lie
at the trial and when Dexter pushes a little he
finds out that they were playing chicken and that
the other guy actually yielded he gave up but matt
crashed into him anyway because he didn't like him
and this is exactly the kind of thing Dex needs to
fit him into his code as he's handing the gun off
we see that he's really starting to think about
this when he has a vision of smashing him in the
face but ultimately leaves without incident
when he arrives back at his cabin he sees a
light turn on inside and he grabs a hatchet before
sneaking in the side door inside he finds his son
Harrison who's now grown looking through his desk
he asks him point blank if he's Dexter Morgan and
before he can answer Deb appears to him warning
him not to tell the truth "you can't everyone
close to you dies that's why we're here" and
he does decide to lie it's difficult but Deb
persists to the point of pulling a bullet out
of her stomach to make the point he doubles
down even though Harrison knows he's his father
and just offers him some money for the bus out
of town the next night promising that he won't
say anything about him breaking into the cabin
after he goes he finds a picture of them together
and he watches him walk away through the window
Deb tells him he did the right thing and that
Harrison will be safer with Hannah and then we see
dexter burn the photo and the fire outside he has
a nightmare where he sees Deb on his ice fishing
line where he's reeling it in and she's grabbed
by a dark figure and pulled under the water
when he wakes up she tells him that she's glad
that she went first and that she loves him for
making it 10 years without a kill the next morning
while he's stalking the deer he's able to approach
it and just as he's reaching his hand out and
having a moment with the animal a shot rings out
and it goes down Matt runs up because of course
he shot it and this time jim follows through with
the idea of knocking him out with the butt of his
rifle and probably the best sequence of the entire
episode he makes the decision to kill matt and
the voice over internal dialogue comes back saying
it's been a long time he puts the deer out of its
misery and then prepares a makeshift kill room
for matt he notices there's some blood coming from
the back of his head and says out loud sorry about
the mess i'm out of practice he puts together a
couple pieces of broken glass as a blood slide
and in the process Matt wakes up aside from the
impromptu feeling of the kill room Dex quickly
falls back into his old routine he wants matt to
tell him what he did he wants him to own it and
when he says or there's a funny call back to him
waving the knife around inside the fishing game
store after a back and forth he gets him to cop
to it and then matt shifts to trying to blame it
all on bad parenting as he begs for his life this
makes him think about his own childhood and how he
wouldn't have had any direction if it wasn't for
Harry and in that moment the seeds are planted for
him to go after Harrison he tells Matt that they
passed the point of no return and things shift
where Matt tries to threaten him he says my dad
knows everyone in this town and he will find you
and rain down a world of pain which is enough for
dex to move on to silencing him we hear him say
tonight's the night hello Dexter Morgan it feels
just like old times but then he gets a phone call
from angela they were supposed to get together
so he lies about why he can't make it and then
when he gets off the phone he says he doesn't need
trophies anymore and that he may be a monster but
he's an evolving monster and then he moves on to
dismembering the body then we see him head to his
truck Deb pops up to ask him what he's doing and
he says not listening to you and in the voice over
we hear him talking about how his life has always
been truth adjacent but starting now there will be
one less lie he goes to the bus station and gives
Harrison a winter jacket before telling him that
he was right i'm dexter morgan your father and
he asked him to come home as he's bringing him
back to the cabin we hear him think about how he's
going to take care of his son the same way harry
took care of him and we get the sense that he's
worried that if there's no one there for Harrison
he may turn out just like dexter as they go inside
we notice that there's blood on the snow outside
the cabin there's a trail of it it's probably
from that wound in the back of Matt's head
and the episode ends there with the familiar
blood theme playing over the closing credits
so yeah i thought it was a pretty solid start the
deer was an interesting end to show who he is now
the stalking without a kill at the end the rarity
of it being albino and his assumed connection to
that it all makes you wonder how long it took
for that to become part of his everyday routine
overall i'm buying his lifestyle it mostly
seems like a good fit for the version of Dexter
who's trying not to indulge his dark passenger it
doesn't seem off for him to live this kind of life
although even before matt was dropped in his lap
it looked like there was doubt that he could keep
it up i really liked how they stress that it's
a small community where there are no secrets
except the glaring one that we know about just
that prolific serial killer that never got caught
hanging out and going line dancing with the chief
of police i thought the way that they held off on
it and then reintroduced the voice over waiting
that far into the episode was really effective
it felt like something was missing and it made
it all the more meaningful when it kicked in
deb had a great introduction even though we knew
she was coming it was still a great surprise
and it did appear that she was an effective coping
mechanism right up to the point where he killed
again given that this is his conscience it's
not really dead but it does distinctly have her
personality it'll be really fun to watch that
internal struggle as he tries not to continue
killing especially now that harrison is in the
picture the sex scene between angela and dex was
pretty effective for developing their relationship
it makes it seem like they've been together for a
while but they're keeping things exciting it also
works to show that they make time for each other
since it seems like they made the decision
to have them not sleep at each other's places
she's got a daughter and they need to have
him off alone so they can maximize the dead
scenes the whole matt situation was convenient
and predictable for me it was the least exciting
part of it but the end result of jim going
full dexter is what's really important i
guess you can make a safe assumption that his
father will be throwing resources at trying to
find him now that he's missing and he seems
to have sway on everyone in town according
to the character description plus we saw his
name on the truck stop which means that he
is definitely a public figure obviously there's
something big brewing with the missing girls
that would hint that there's someone who's going
to be more interesting to dexter than matt was
there's also some little details here that might
come up again later the stolen pies that logan
recovered the protest and that look from ed olsen
and of course the girl that angela helped out at
the bar i think it did what it needed to do it
set things up and i'm interested to see where
things go from here really curious to find out how
harrison ended up there in the first place and how
dexter is going to explain the whole faking his
death thing and that seems like a pretty good
place to leave things let me know in the comments
what you thought of the first episode where you
think things are going what are you hoping to see
please like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't already
and thanks for watching i'll talk to you soon